[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sake on
very excited to be talking about a
sustainable and fulfilling way of life
we have re Nizam joining us on the show
hello hello
thanks for not of course really really
happy be here yes super pumped super
from very grateful that we met at June's
event yes just this last weekend very
grateful for him and his thought
leadership and bring people like you
know us together to continue interacting
and and just even got to give the man
the shout out
you know interdependent capitalism the
one such such a good book such a good
book guys check it out doing in such a
such a thought leader in so many so many
regards so is re I'm very excited to be
talking to her about this subject for
those that don't know the background re
went to Nueva High School in the wave of
school that is in Hillsborough right in
the Bay Area and then he started a house
system there across great house system
we'll be talking about that he then made
swap he may start a ryan creative he did
some work with carnegie mellon with neo
sensory and then he is now working on
the pantheon which we're gonna be
unpacking in detail and we'll be talking
about a lot regarding building solutions
for renegotiating our relationship with
technology and with each other and this
is great cuz Ari is 19 mm-hmm he is a
symbolic systems major at Stanford
sophomore well have freshman my freshman
freshman and let's jump into this from
this big history perspective so you know
we find ourselves as stewards of Earth
now and there's a lot of complications
with you know eight billion people
exponential technology so what is your
current
synthesis on the state of humanity yeah
I think what's happening right now is
really really interesting especially
from kind of a young person's
perspective and seeing kind of how
technology is influencing my generation
and the generations a little bit younger
than me which I say generations because
I think there's some research going on
at Stanford that we were actually
talking about this earlier is that it's
looking like you know where as a
generation used to maybe be 20 years or
around that timeframe now it can get
down to two or three years because the
rate of Technology is going so fast that
you're actually seeing these huge
generational gaps between you know me
and your 7 year difference or me and my
sister a two year difference radically
different in the way that we use
technology or even interact with each
other and so that that's I think this
really interesting landscape were now in
where you have these micro generations
you know every 2 3 years you have kind
of a whole different group of people but
being served by the same education
system by the same kind of ways of
living right one of the things I think
we'll talk a bit about is kind of how
the built environment stays the same
it's really hard to change the built
environment you know we'd have to get in
here with sledgehammers really to make
any of this stuff move around but
technology is blasting off right it's on
this exponential curve and then kind of
caught in the middle it's culture right
its culture kind of trying to try to
anchor itself between these two forces
and its really getting pulled apart and
so that's I think interesting visual
yeah oh cool okay so we got this
physical world that we live in and then
digital world it's way easy your main
value right manipulate and then we're
stuck in the culture which is kind of
being like what is going on right yeah
and it's it's really interesting how how
those are kind of in play with each
other right because you have technology
which i think is kind of the frame that
everything is kind of happening in right
you know by and by technology I don't
mean like I mean of course I mean the
iPhone and everything but I also mean
you know agricultural revolution as
being a technology a technology being a
mix of like kind of culture like a
knowledge system with like a physical
built environment implements so didn't
know how of how to farm
then the the hose and the shovels and
things like that in the class and then
you know the Industrial Revolution the
know-how of the assembly line and
manufacturing and kind of if this than
that and then the the built environment
of the factory in the loom and the you
know the mechanical mechanical
implements of that and now we're having
a similar thing where you know it's this
idea of the connected world and the
connected web with the implementation of
it in our apps and then our phones and
things like that and so that's kind of
the frame I think is technology and then
within that you have the built
environment which is very static and
then you have kind of like I said
culture in between and those those two
are really in play a lot because if you
see I think in sapiens they talk about
how the built environment in the
medieval ages a lot of the kids would
live in these big halls they'd sleep in
the same halls right where everyone
could see each other and and you'd come
all your public life had to be conducted
in the town square right or in the in
the market or in the forum or whatever
that is and that's because their
societies built on reputation right it
really matters who you are because you
know there's only a couple thousand
people living in these communities so it
really matters you know are you going to
return that loan are you gonna be a nice
person are you gonna do these things
those things really matter in those
contexts there's no digital space to go
anonymous right exactly and that's
reflective of I mean and they maybe they
had a masquerade day but that was the
one day they were anonymous and that was
you know there's this whole thing that's
because their whole society's belt on
identity right it's a that's why last
names are like William's son right or
even in Iran you know I think my last
name is my great-grandfather's
profession which is just the organizer
of the bazaar its Nasim which means
organizer so they cut off I guess the
bizarre part but you know they just we
just started doing that and that's kind
of around the time period of kind of the
Industrial Revolution and stuff like
that when it used to be all about who
are you who are you the son of what have
you done what's your reputation and now
it's all about you know parents give
their kids their own bedroom with a door
they can lock right you put up your own
posters on the wall you do your own
thing
that's because we have this idea
that you know it doesn't matter what the
other kids at school say about you it's
it's you're beautiful for you it's the
individual as opposed to valuing
yourself in the community it's now
valuing yourself as the individual and
the built environment reflects that
right the bedroom versus the hall right
you can go to the grocery store you
don't even have to look at anyone to get
your business done it's not in a town
market right you don't have to have
these relationships with buyers and
sellers yourself it's all kind of
abstracted it's one one level up and
that's because of the culture right the
culture is saying we want to be
individual we want to be anonymous we
want to be self-contained as opposed to
different this is a lot of consciousness
is yummy
keep doing it yeah so so that's kind of
how the built environment and culture
are playing with each other is it you
know but the thing is with that is that
these changes kind of before used to be
happening over hundreds of years or
thousands of years right the Industrial
Revolution even it was you know only 200
years ago but it still took a while to
get there and it's spread across the
world at a pretty slow pace now we're
kind of having these like micro
revolutions when someone releases a new
app that's a new format of interacting
with other people when someone releases
20 years the genome went from a hundred
million dollars to sequence to a hundred
dollars absolutely that's a different
that's a revolution right there and if
you're looking at you know uber just
coming a couple years ago that's a
completely different built environment
right these are this is a completely
different idea of how life should be and
will be and you know like with Google
subsidiary sidewalk labs doing stuff
with like moving sidewalks are adapting
to different times of the day I mean
that stuff that has a profound impact on
on the way we live and so I if to answer
the question very long-winded answer to
the question but the question of kind of
where do we find ourselves right now I
think where we find ourselves is in is
in culture being strained being pulled
by a built environment that is is too
static for what's happening now it
wasn't too static you know back in 1500s
or even seventeen to eighteen hundred
maybe even then it was
- static but now I mean people are
living in the same 50 you know 1950s
floor plans with with iPhones and that
doesn't work because in the 1950s you
want to go hang out with your friends
you go outside you can do all these
things it doesn't matter that you have
kind of this weird isolating room in
your house it doesn't matter that you're
in these suburbs which are these weird
enclaves of nuclear families it doesn't
really matter because you go out onto
the street to play with your friends you
go into the living room that's the only
place you can find those people so
that's where you go right and now we
have a world that still looks like that
physically but now you can be on your
computer and access all of it so you
don't even have to leave and the
implications of that are there's a ton
of health implications the fact that
you're not moving the fact that you're
not getting fresh air the fact that
you're not active the Lord looking at
humans and not eyes exactly and and
there's huge emotional impacts right
even human connection we know is so much
more fulfilling than interacting with
static photos on social media or even or
even in FaceTime you know there's a lot
that you can lose even and stuff like
that and how often do you I mean some
people FaceTime their friends a lot but
you don't FaceTime every person you talk
to on the Internet most the time is
texting as it is so the huge drop in
empathy that comes with that especially
for kids growing up talking to the
friends online and not building the
repertory in person and and you know
also just meant like mental health wise
being in a room the same room every day
in a hunched posture you know there's a
lot of great stuff we were talking about
kind of influence from the east there's
a lot of stuff that says you know the
way your body is is the position you're
in and this is I mean Amy Cuddy right
the second most watched TED talk of all
time is about how our bodies kind of
influence our mindsets and if you're
hunched over kind of staring at a screen
closed off right that's a big difference
first moving around back
yeah active reaching towards your goal
that's what the clicking door isn't
right like these
it sounds like whoa I'm making a big
stretch but it does make make a big
difference when you kind of lose
connection with her with your own body
which does have a much bigger I think
impact on people's minds let me let me
take a synthesis stat yes that to
synthesize let's see what I can do here
okay
so you started us off talking about this
all has to do with time I can die let me
see if I can explain how that you have
this the first you start off these micro
generations now right we're all the way
down to this and the technology scale of
things is is now within just two or
three years a generation of this group
of 2 to 3 years it's like 15 to 17
year-olds but then there's the 13 to 15
year olds how the what tech they're
using etc that that they're using
different tech different ecosystems is
all in the digital sphere right there's
a physical sphere cultures in the middle
there's the pull that's happening what
are we doing how are we dancing with
that but then in the scale of time you
were explaining how the just the the
skills of these revolutions difference
like good yeah yeah genome being
decreasing cost like that in 20 years
you know you could barely push an item
across the Silk Road four months three
months yeah so yeah this is this is the
scales and our are crazy in comparison
so that seems like to be a oppressing
yeah theme as time and culture being
smashed between the physical yeah on the
digital yeah and and what I mean when I
say culture is getting smashed and I
talked a lot about kind of how built
environment influences culture but the
what I mean by culture is getting pulled
apart is is what I was talking about
with you know someone in a room alone
and we've seen kind of how anxiety rates
have gone up in recent years I think in
the 80s there was about like 15 percent
18 percent of college students said they
had anxiety now it's up to 40 percent
right you look at in the 1950s I think
you have the average American has three
close friends now they have two right
just kind of going down on these metrics
that I think mean a lot because we feel
them and I think you've been you can
look around and and maybe it's because
we're talking about it more and I think
that's part of it or you can't rule that
out but I think we're also seeing a lot
of these kind of mental health crises
and and just well-being standards really
really plummeting at the hands of our
environments not adapting to the way
technology is going and our culture not
being able to because it's it's stuck
it's about the environment it's stuck in
the built environment it's also stuck in
the biological systems which evolve over
much slower time periods exactl systems
this is a this is a very very crucial
point the physical world versus the
digital world and how what's happening
in the pulling apart yeah sure I really
glad you took us there with the big
history that's beautiful so then now
this is cool because then you as at
nineteen are seeing this and I think
this also has to do with like a
testament of like you know a strong
strong family strong up brings don't
community for you and then you know
doing a new wave of school right these
these things coming together have made
your perspective kind of what it's why
it's so strong in multidisciplinary and
you're like I see all these problems I'm
gonna make like a really powerful like
work life and community solution to it
to to this pre that tell us about how
everything got started for you with a
new wave of school how did how did you
even figure out that that's where you
wanted to go like what were you like
when you were younger getting into that
yeah so I'm from the Bay Area I'm from
Silicon Valley my parents immigrated
here from Iran and they they didn't just
immigrate themselves they immigrated
with the whole the whole crew so my dad
side and my mom side came
and I was very much my mom side lived a
lot closer to us so very much raised
kind of in a mini Persian community
there with my grandma my aunt and do you
know what year that was your peeps came
over they came over right before the
Revolution so it wasn't it wasn't cut
because necessarily at the revolution
but I think the water was getting a
little bit hot and they came I think 75
76 Wendish when the Shah was getting
getting bounced out yeah right before I
think they just shot over right before
and one of my aunt's came over later
after the iran-iraq war so a little bit
of a trickle I was like nine years old
when that was happening it was
fascinating for me I don't know why I
was taking interest as a nine year old
but at any rate it's good to have you
with us you know and I just want to
bring up the the tensions and the the
global narrative for what we should be
concerned with you know my brothers and
sisters are scattered all over the
planet and I just want to throw that in
go back to you know no absolutely yeah
welcome to the United States of America
yeah you meet a lot of the Persian
people I think you'll meet in the u.s.
are either my age ish because they're
the kids of the immigrants of that
period so a lot of first gen kids around
my age and then you also get kind of the
parents and then you also get a lot of
PhD students still coming now but raised
kind of with that context in Silicon
Valley and my parents were kind of both
on the tech the tech boom and DEF made
their livelihoods that way and so that
was a big part of just our context
growing up was kind of knowing what was
going on and and my parents having the
latest stuff in the house just because
that's what they were working on and
that's what they needed for their jobs
and especially what my dad needed for
his because he was working with Yahoo at
the time and that was right on kind of
the internet stuff so that was kind of
you know the talk in the household is
kind of about this stuff growing up and
also just coming from another place in
the world not necessarily seeing it just
as an economic thing that's happening
but seeing it in the context of the rest
of the world
and being told you know you're growing
up you know saying you know you come
from this this long history this long
line of people from this other place and
that kind of grounding you in the
ancient time period or the grounding you
in two thousand years ago and giving you
a reason to care about that time period
and not just the now because I think a
lot of people raised in Silicon Valley
really care a lot about the now and
that's beautiful and thankfully I was
given a little bit of perspective of
well where do you come from and where
are we coming from as a species to and I
think that is definitely intertwined
with my Persian heritage because my mom
was very very passionate about making
sure she transmitted that to us and that
kind of giving us the intra perspective
but that's so important oh yeah that's
so so important we we all Armenian here
and yeah absolutely yeah very very
similar and and just how blessed it is
to be able to have a this very
interesting cross cultural upbringing
right yeah when you get those two
perspectives of like what is Armenia
very wrong like what is now you're
living in the United States what is that
right and then you'll be the second
language is also very fascinating for
what that does - yeah yeah and I think
it makes it so that you kind of have to
think about the forces that are acting
on you and that you're playing with in
especially as I you know you realize
that stuff as you get older you're just
kind of playing with it when you're a
kid but you know you realize oh what
does it mean to be a first generation
kid and where do my people even come
from or and I don't even know too much
about this country than my parents are
from and learning about that and then
yes kind of getting stuff in context so
that's that's definitely one way to zoom
out and and kind of see where we are is
having to think about where do I come
from myself was a great way to start
with that so I went to a Catholic school
until about fourth grade right next to
my my house I was like five minutes away
and we were not Catholic which which was
an interesting dynamic when we were
there because I think you know even
today I'm probably
one of the like 20 of the kids from my
grade that can grow a beard you know
like just very few number of people that
looked like me at that school and so in
that environment I definitely hung on to
that I think that fact that I think
Persians are considered Caucasians or
something so I leaned really hard into
that and I was like well you know I'm
not Arab whatever I'm Caucasian right
Persians are Caucasians I'm what do you
guys with being one of us guys you know
all of them have been infiltrated nobody
holds oculi on ignorance in this plant
yeah I know I'm sure I absolutely agree
but yeah just being in a context is very
different from kind of the context I was
raised in and trying to kind of conform
to that and that is being kind of a
social thing but but from an academic
perspective the way they were teaching
wasn't really resonating with me and my
mom had always said you know education
is or school as part of your education
and and not necessarily all of it right
so she waited long learner baby that's
the goal right that's the goal and so
she had us doing a lot of stuff over the
summers and learning kind of ahead of
time and so I was sitting in like my
third grade class and this is a story a
lot of Nueva kids actually talk about
but you'll be sitting there and you know
you you finished the cursive or whatever
it is you say okay can I do the next
thing and they said well you gotta wait
for the class to catch up and you're
like oh okay and you wait and I told my
mom that and she was like all right it's
time to look at somewhere that lets you
go at your own pace and it was amazing
because we found a wave and I went there
and I was you know the dumbest kid in
the room right off the bat and you
experienced again at Stanford later
exactly yeah and they didn't like what I
experienced when I moved to Silicon
Valley yeah yeah exactly and I think it
was great actually coming to Nueva
before Stanford because I was already
used to that and I think when you get
get into an environment like that as a
kid you see it as really great you know
you're like oh this kid knows all this
stuff about something else this kid
knows all so you don't really have the
ego yet or the the sense of self yet to
be like oh I'm because this guy's great
you're like
oh this guy is really great I'm not that
great but this guy is really really
really awesome and they're a lot a lot
of boys and girls that Nueva who would
like that and these are like little
local maximums of of knowledge
definitely and so you can jump to a
higher local maxima college what you
want to do throughout your life FM - to
continue yummy yummy
and the way the setting of the wave it's
it's like 33 acres of forest the lower
middle school are 33 acres of forest up
in Burlingame and hands-on learning it's
based a lot on the principles of design
thinking and on project-based learning
so a lot of times you know the final
project like wouldn't be an essay or
wouldn't be something like that it'd be
like okay how do you want to represent
what you learned in this and it was it
was really fantastic for me I think for
some of the kids there especially it
happened I think more in the high school
but because in the middle school it was
a smaller class size it was only like 50
55 kids in my grade and even maybe like
30 before sixth grade so many teachers
with it was a really high ratio of
students to teachers I think for for our
in fourth grade I remember when I came
in we had four teachers for the 30 30
kids so so a bunch yeah that's so cool
and really like really great attention
from the teachers and stuff like that
this Bluetooth SIG was so damn true that
one-on-one mentorship just Rockets kids
out multiples to standard deviation
right yeah right I mean you got got to
get that one-on-one mentorship
absolutely yeah yeah and so I feel like
there was a lot of that and a lot of
teachers that took special interest in
kids that they saw going in certain
directions and you know like there were
certain math classes but we had some
kids that were just off with one guy
doing something in the library because
he was on a whole nother level
everything like that little shout-out to
you know
and the other skillset is being fostered
absolutely that's so critical their
feedback is you know instantaneous like
oh whoa they're advancing fast giver
more right you know where are they going
where is their interest you see
something and you know some of these
kids were just unbelievable like I came
there from a very kind of a really
wonderful safe place I think that the
school I went to was really great but I
come into this place and kids are in the
forts you know we that's what we called
the forest oh yeah it's worth forts
running around and this one kid had made
a whole economy based on the fertiliser
crystals you'd find in the ground and if
he found more he would devalue the price
and all this stuff I mean and I mean
that that kids crazy and just like
really really impressive stuff some
people had like mining companies where
they go you know dig up like tree tree
bark and ground it up to make like henna
it wasn't real Hana but they called it
that or people would build these really
really beautiful forts and everything
and it's just a very magical place to be
in a lot of a lot of space to play and a
lot of space to like get dirty and that
acreage hands-on yeah which i think is
really important especially we were
talking about you know the physical the
physical stuff and kids interacting in
the physical world and building stuff
with their hands not just with the keys
and so that was a really really
wonderful experience growing up there so
I was there fourth grade fifth grade and
then sixth grade the middle school it's
very similar to the lower school we
still went down to the floor it still
did our stuff and really started getting
interested in design there I had been
interested in art I had always been
drawing and sketching everywhere you
know on little notebooks and little
the hotel you know by the phone they
always have that little notepad and we
traveled a lot as I can and that's
definitely a big part of my growth to
read about graffiti you tag anything
along the way loose no I the first the
first introduction I had to graffiti was
in in the high school and I did a class
on graffiti in this two-week period
called intersession when you get back
from winter break that did this thing
I'm graffiti and I took it we didn't
like tag everything for real better yet
it was cool that they had that where to
travel to we so much doubt that was
actually probably besides kind of New
Haven the learning environment foster
there we went to a hundred and six
countries oh my good from when I was a
kid until I was fifteen oh it's kind of
will be slowed down and that was kind of
really my parents like a day or
something in each or two or do yeah I
think the shortest we'd ever do is like
three days like two or three days yeah
and the longest would you know be like a
week or two weeks
yeah wanted to take which is just
ridiculous like even thinking back on it
you know some of the places like blur or
you have to really go back and figure it
out but I'm really happy the way my mom
did it and I've only really realized
this as I got got older shout out to mom
I love you very much
moms always give like that and then
later you realize how much family has
given right yeah yeah and so she would
have us like we didn't really know why
but she'd have us look at the Wikipedia
pages and look at like the GDP and the
PPP and the you know GDP per capita PPP
and and per capita I said that and like
the Gini index and the HD HDI like the
Human Development Index and Ginny's for
any quality and service do all this
other stuff and look at like the major
imports and exports and their neighbors
that's every she really I think wanted
to get a get out like kind of axioms
like the the things that happened over
and over and over again as you look
around the world like she'd always say
neighbors hate each other because
they've always had conflicts over the
years so border
over the border or religion so we saw
that all throughout the travels you know
you'd go to one country go to the other
country they'd be roasting each other
you know the tour guide so just be
sending shots at each other basically
this place we went and it was really
cool she'd kind of have these these
themes that we'd explore over time one
of the themes very morbid theme but she
had us explore genocide a lot she wanted
us to really understand that and so we I
think we've been to pretty much the
sites of all most of the major genocides
we went Armenia went to Auschwitz you
know went to in Cambodia you know we
went to Rwanda we went to Kigali and
it's not morbid we're getting ready to
normalize that [ __ ] another day in
genocide don't worry about it I know I
mean hang on the quotes another day in
paradise
yeah but now the day in paradise it's
really crazy and I think that was a
unreal experience too because there's
like the the ten step framework for
genocide so like the first couple steps
are about like humanizing authorizing
awesome man which each drink could be
Mary you're a good kid I keep up the
good work we're all counting on ya this
is so crucial that mom did this yeah
vamp family exposing young children to
to travel and then to you know
import/export GDP Gini yeah this is so
crucial it really gives the true picture
of how things are happening in our world
outside of the little bedroom right
you're right outside a little bit and
you know I think there's one way to do
travel which is sunscreen on your nose
and hitting all the best like Instagram
photo spots which is now kind of a more
common thing and there's the other way
which is a little bit deeper and you
know I won't like lie and say we you
know we didn't go sightseeing and we
didn't go to the touristy spots and you
didn't take the pictures because we did
you know and and some of the reflections
I've done is I've gotten older like we
went to 14 countries on the African
continent
and kind of understanding some of the
you know the things that the things that
were a play there that I didn't realize
as a kid you know when you're going on a
safari are you doing stuff like that
it's you know where's the heritage of
that from right that's a colonial thing
and kind of understanding where some of
that comes from and oh wow we're staying
at this beautiful resort on the
Serengeti you know what does that mean
who who's that at the benefit for at the
cost of and my roommate in college is
from Kenya and not he's from a little
bit outside of Nairobi from the Kuro
which is a little bit more west and just
living with him and hearing his
perspectives on staff has absolutely
kind of rewritten some of the ideas that
I had about the travels that we did
there and how much I understood what was
going on when we were visiting those
countries so crucial to have friends
from around the world that you can have
great conversation with ask questions
about their life and their family and
what was going on in that part of the
world so so crucial Horton so could you
gain a better more well-rounded
perspective of life absolutely so yeah I
think travel is huge and I think it's
something I'm still really interested in
I want to go back to a lot of the places
that we went as an adult that's you know
being able to go some of the places that
were maybe unsafe for us to go as kids
yes you know or with the context that I
have now or the understandings that I'm
continuing to develop you know going
back and saying okay there are a lot of
bullet holes in Sarajevo and Bosnia when
we went yeah
what like I noticed that when I was a
kid but what does that mean where is
that from and I think as you get older
you you start to put those things in
perspective but having the data in the
back of your head having seen those
things yeah then everything kind of
clicks when you're when you're older so
yeah you're really are
call about the on Wikipedia about
something and then you go oh my gosh I
saw the best thought yeah and then it
clicks in a deeper level you can even
experience that rereading a book a
couple years later definitely and you'll
see that you're definitely new
perspective on the world you're just
like whoa I'm absorbing this in a new
way right right
or you know a conclusion that's reached
at the end that when you apply it to the
beginning again it puts everything in a
whole new new new light which is
interesting so so nuevas cool + trap +
travel were two of the big reasons why
you are who you are yeah I would say and
I think mentorship like what you were
saying that bloom bloom - yeah bloom to
Sigma bloom terrible parents as well as
teachers in school absolutely so
definitely a lot of that I had a teacher
wonderful wonderful teacher Kim sax been
a mentor to two of my best friends as
well and she saw me running around and
the fourths you know in like fourth
grade and she was like hey how about you
come over to the to the end to the
engineering shop that they called the AI
lab the engineering engineering lab and
got me in there and started teaching me
very hands-on you know the Design
Thinking principles the ideas of user
testing and going out and and the way
that she packaged it I mean is fourth
great ya and fifth grade is when we
really started doing a lot of stuff yeah
see this is another one of those things
this is a really cutting edge school I
mean if you're not only doing all the
outdoor stuff but but you're doing all
this user testing and been designed yeah
in the fifth grade I mean that's really
setting you up to think like absolutely
look at these things
why how why do people design them this
ability how can I design things yeah
what do we learn from this and that yeah
and it's it's wonderful cuz Stanford is
you know I kind of pioneered some of
those approaches and she learned a lot
of that from Stanford her time at
Stanford and it kind of had a connection
with the University so she'd take us to
the D school there and have us learn
from some of the people there and then
when we got older in high school a
couple friends and I we'd actually go
back to the D school and help teach
workshops for graduates and stuff like
that because they're like oh if a kid
can do this then surely I can do this
right and we're like yeah it is this is
you know we've been doing it since we
were kids
not because we're you know super
geniuses but just because we were taught
the framework and given you know the D
attention from from someone who was
dedicated to help teaching us and so
that kind of mindset the Design Thinking
mindset and you know a lot of people
like think it's very hand wavy and oh
you know apply and Design Thinking to
this and I do think it gets overused a
little bit you know some people to
design things that solution to
everything I don't think that's
necessarily true but in it it does kind
of unlock this way of thinking for you
that's okay there's a problem instead of
thinking about oh I suddenly have the
best solution to this problem the first
thing I ever thought it was the best
decision is gone you have no idea what
you're talking about right you gotta go
talk to the people who are experiencing
the problem if the if the problem is
happening to you
reflecting on a deeply going to others
who are experiencing the problem or have
the need as I call it that's how I feel
about the current version one of social
media networks that we kind of have the
10-15 year incumbents that this is not
the AHA last call networks we got a
absolutely update the code make these
better absolutely is now I I know I
wanna I want to hit on so yeah so so
many so much more to to talk about yeah
so this design thinking mindset that
you're talking about now it gave you the
and in the trial and everything it kind
of gave you the edge to see that you
know you wanted to create the housing
new housing style this cross grade
housing system at a new wave oh yeah so
what that be that I started doing that
in my junior year okay of my of high
school yeah so learned a lot in seventh
grade was the first like so in fifth
grade and stuff like that we were doing
design thinking projects we were you
know interviewing people at Kaiser
Permanente and thinking about like
medical solutions seventh grade
it never ends the stream of like
brilliant things it's interviewing
people like guys who per minute eight
Wow yeah seventh grade was the first
time we ever did entrepreneurship so
seventh grade is we
they said actually figure out a like a
product type of idea so me and one of my
friends we thought about like a little
like it was before pity hi brought to
you by in a wave of school a really
great place okay I can tell you it is a
really great place and I hope it really
does stay to you know maintain its its
current way of operation and I'll say as
a graduate someone who loves me very
deeply I will say I'm worried about the
impact the college process is having on
the school because with because it you
stand at eighth grade so there was kind
of a hard stop and so it didn't really
feel the pressure that was coming down
from the college system to make kids
that looked a certain way or anything so
they had a ton of freedom and these kids
would you know these guys are really
bright kids they'd go into high school
and they'd adapt to their new high
school and then they look like a great
candidate for college without you know
messing with that like really nice and
we've experienced and what happened in
the high school anyway and I think it
still leaks leaves ahead of in a lot of
the ways that was doing things from
other high schools give me give me a
young person that doesn't have any of
their SAT scores or any of that crap and
if they know how to do entrepreneurship
they know how to like interview industry
people and build products they don't to
do that I mean if they know how to be in
the woods and like make with their hands
I mean it's game over time over sin it's
way better than the SAT right and the
problem is is our high school had to you
know the first two years yeah I'll even
push it I'll say the first year was
there was only us the freshman and then
sophomores and so there was still no
college pressure it's when we became
sophomores and the sophomores became
juniors is when they started feeling oh
crap we really got to start having you
know people come in and talk about the
college process start getting SAT scores
and stuff like this test scores right
and our first graduating class sent ten
of the seventy kids to Stanford ten like
one seventh of the grade was great and
set this bar that that's what our school
produces so it was all happy you know
running around in the meadow before when
it was just the middle school and he was
all happy you know I knew Ava until we
got our first class into college and
then the parents who used to be looking
at
you know cassoulet across will spare all
these other schools around here start
saying oh wait isn't new wave of the one
that's gonna get our kid into college
right oh and you get this this pressure
so thankfully we got out I think right
before the the worst of it is happening
and and I mean I love my school so much
I'm not I don't know what the effect of
this is but I know that a lot more
people are applying now to get into the
school and a lot of kids that I think
you know might learn better in a
traditional environment there are a lot
of kids that learn great in a
traditional environment you know and
want some of the discontent students I
found in my school where the students
were like why aren't why can't I know my
grade at every time why
you know don't I learn the rules and
then get to apply them why is it all
experiencial and kind of you know
wishy-washy which is great for me but
not great for other kids you know yeah
and I think that's one of the problems
is when you don't have that that bloom
to and you don't have that you know
mentor-student relationship when it's
kind of prepackaged you have to be
really careful the package you're
stepping into because you have to make
sure it's at least it's more aligned
than the other ones right and so I think
you we can get this problem where if a
lot of kids come to an environment like
this that would actually do better in
traditional environments would actually
feel more at home in traditional moments
you're putting them in an environment
maybe they've never been exposed to it
maybe they don't like right because it
gets them into college or something like
that
yeah yeah you know it's number one it's
not great for them number two it
influences and changes the culture of
the school to be oh well it's all fine
and good you know that they can run
around the force but college and so yeah
like when are they getting their SAT
scores of it which is something we never
used to care about so I really hope
sincerely that the fact that our grade
sent a bunch of kids to really great
colleges and the grade above us and I
think the current year is also going to
do really well in the college process
doesn't influence the the school I think
it will unfortunately but of course it's
influencing it at extreme-right rates I
mean that that first moment of
inflection one
yeah one out of every seven students
from the class got into Stanford
eyeballs
everyone was looking at other school
saying oh a new wave is this hippie
school who cares right and then suddenly
I think all the parents in Silicon
Valley started looking at not all the
pants tones but a lot of them that may
have kind of dismissed it before said oh
wait is that the golden golden ticket is
that the school that's gonna get our
kids there as opposed to that other and
then the other problem of all the kids
coming with different learning styles
and you gotta have the right learning
styles for the kids and great
mentorships and and that's that's a very
very interesting but what you bring up
and how often that happens around around
the world for these schools that are
that are that had the mold these moments
of shining right and then we're impacted
by the collegiate or running up against
a system that is static or this kind of
these these like squatting existing kind
of traditional systems you know when
that happens you know I think bad things
happen that's huge they are basically
just squatting and
yeah yeah yes let's go yeah yeah so so
for the house system houses so learned a
lot about kind of how to implement ideas
you have and whatnot and back to the
idea that you know when I was a freshman
there were there was us and then there
was a sophomores what was happening when
we started to become a bigger school is
that we had never had upperclassmen so
we had never learned how to make cross
cross grade connections beyond the fact
that you know there was 200 kids in a
school you're gonna know everyone
because you know there was like 70 kids
per grade plus the teachers when we were
there the first year so when we got our
new freshman class in and we were
sophomores and they were juniors I was
like something feels off you know we're
not really interacting with the freshman
and the freshman definitely aren't
interacting with the juniors because
they've because the juniors have never
had the experience of being real
upperclassmen and we had never had the
experience of being the middle child you
know just like none of this stuff was
happening right and when they became
seniors and I became a junior you know I
barely knew the names of the freshmen I
I went out of my way to but you know a
lot of the seniors didn't a lot of even
the sauces didn't any of them yeah
there's only 70 of us right so I was
like okay something needs to change and
how I met you is through Jeremy yeah and
Jeremy Jeremy yoonsun of Jinyan Jeremy
Ewan was my buddy in the middle school
so I loved that system in the middle
school and I wish we had something kind
of similar to it in the high school but
I thought oh we could really make this
exciting we could really dress this up
and kind of my love for design and stuff
like that came into it and so the house
system what that means because we don't
we didn't live on campus what the house
system means is that one fourth of every
grade was put in a in one of four houses
together so 25% of each class isn't a
house together and if you have the
banners you can yes you can show them
they're all the banners up and so design
and I designed them so actually design
these cut these sewed these by hand
they're 12 feet long
yeah with my ground with my aunt on a
Persian sewing machine that was breaking
down like halfway doing we have to call
my grandma and be like wait how do we
fix
and she was like like just do this so we
fix it but that was a really fun
experience with her but I designed these
to represent the different houses so
this is how the seniors juniors
sophomores and freshmen would integrate
yes so the idea was that you know a
quarter of each grade would be in each
of the houses they'd be with you know
the other grades group like that then
there would be families which are two
people from each grade in a family so -
seniors - junior to sophomore new
freshmen so you have a couple people in
each grade that you know and then there
were house meetings where the whole
house would get together and you see
people from all the different grades and
then they were they were like field days
and like games and competitions where
you would you know do tug-of-war and
beanbag toss all this stuff to try to
build like kind of a community in within
the houses this is real community that
that was the goal that's really the goal
kind of taking as well and moving into
real world now definitely with which
we're gonna talk about this is so cool
yeah so that was kind of what if there's
games over the floor so they're named
after constellations the only one that's
not named after the constellation is is
Lycos which is the wolf because because
lupus is wolf in Latin and is the
constellation but it's also an
autoimmune disease and so you just have
to be careful with it those things so
that was the initial name and then we
realized okay we got to change it and
that's really what you learned with this
sort of stuff yeah is we we made a bunch
of bunch of mistakes on the rollout you
know like that which I just didn't
realize the name we were you know
scrambling to get the names out and I
didn't even look it up really because I
knew what it wasn't Latin and I saw it
on Google Trends like a we're fine and
you know it actually caused a scandal
the first week that we put it out
because someone someone's grandpa had so
that was really helpful training for me
to understand you know when you launch
something you gotta be real real careful
with how you do and you gotta be real
careful with the names of things and
whatnot so that like ghost was the name
of someone's dog that died and then they
complain right you changed it to
something else so there's always there's
always gonna be something and we and it
was a really great experience because I
we went to a bunch of problems
throughout you know
of you know like the first week there
people are getting really really into it
people were like howling like wolves
across the the schoolyard oh yeah so
this one is Lycos which is the wolf
you got Ursa which is the bear you've
got Aquila which is the eagle and you
have series which is the the stag we
were doing the sir any in high and those
little too long sweets there and there's
a there was actually an interesting
design challenge when we updated the
brandings me and my my my really good
friend and partner and all these a lot
of these ventures that I've done ohm
when we oh yeah with om like the sound
when you meditate shut oh yeah hey so he
was working on yeah so we so we in my
senior year we worked on it together in
junior year I was working with with a
girl in my grade named Jessa and we
rolled this out and then ohm and I had
kind of redid the branding our senior
year to kind of leave it in a good place
yeah it's still rolling it's still
rolling yeah and we had some lieutenants
that we were working with in the younger
grades that are that are running it now
at the school and I need to go back and
check on that this is such a good idea
for that in the inter class right
intergenerational that was really the
goal because what generation is no one
grade like I know it's right
micro gradient micro grade so yeah this
is very cool so this was the family that
you'd get to write be cool because then
the two seniors could mentor the two
juniors right so two sophomores exactly
they could learn from what the freshmen
are learning it's yeah very cool I mean
if you look at the MIT it's it's
actually part of the inspiration of the
name for Pantheon which is the project
I'm working on now but MIT has this this
thing called MIT Pantheon it's in their
Media Lab where they basically look at
the cultural production of history of
figures over history and they rank them
based on like how many people or like
which people have kind of created the
most like cultural production and the
top five
it goes I think it's Plato Socrates
Jesus
Aristotle Alexander the Great and if you
look at those five people what I
realized that they all have in common
besides Jesus right Jesus is the only
one who could get in there besides these
guys these guys knew each other right
Socrates is the mentor of Plato Plato is
the mentor of Aristotle Aristotle's the
mentor of Alexander the Great into
through 16 and Jesus that you know the
probably one of the most impactful
figures in history the only guy who can
get in that that chain of mentorship
because that's what separates us as
humans right you know ants one of them
goes off a cliff one of them walks the
right way it takes a whole you know
biological generation for that for that
mistake to propagate right the fact that
that ant doesn't have kids or I mean I
guess ants are a bad idea because I have
the queen that lion right the fact that
Lions genes don't don't propagate is
like the learning that happens there
right but humans can actually stack you
know you you make a mistake in your life
you know you name a house the wrong name
you can tell someone right then don't
make the mistake that I made and you're
stacking knowledge on top of each other
in in your own lifetime and so that's
that was a big inspiration there it was
seeing you know the four four the five
most impactful people have created the
most cultural production in all of
history knew each other right
we're mentors and passed that knowledge
down yeah of course Alexander the Great
is gonna be able to conquer my people
you know in 30 years because he knew
because he had the he had the the
intergenerational knowledge from from
Socrates from Plato from Aris all coming
down all into him and you know he never
lost a battle right how do you do that
you don't the only the only the only way
you do that is when you know the
forefathers of modern philosophy or
basically your uncle's yeah that's the
only way you do that and so that's
that's something I've thought a lot
about
and so yeah that was the house that
juiciest juiciest cutting-edge knowledge
down into the minds of children as
they're being born into the world you
know we need dumb people will you stop
that you know I just don't understand
what you don't understand about the
whole natural selection manipulation
thing and you know they don't want a
bunch of informed critical thinking
citizens creating a better world there's
no money and peace love and
understanding knock off your [ __ ] you
know that's kind of the problem right is
that there's no money in doing like the
great stuff and so in in high school did
these other three problems one of them
was a nap one of them was a design firm
with home but in college what I'm really
excited about doing it just quick some
of those designs oh yeah we have on some
of the designs yeah I went over that
quickly but but this is this is my
dribble walk was first swap was first
yeah that was for a really quick contact
info sharing so I'd have my phone in
your pocket vacation yeah basically the
idea was you know we were we were
meeting all these amazing people in high
school for the first time meeting all
these amazing people around Silicon
Valley and just it being super clunky to
get in touch with them so that it was
kind of making that experience a little
more seamless and they don't conk you a
business card it's still it's so clear
we never we didn't solve it never
actually solve it
yeah and because we stopped the company
at in sophomore year because we're like
oh right now we gotta focus on college
right and then the things we could do
alongside alongside the college process
and alongside the work we were doing was
freelance design work in this design
firm with me and ohm so this is your
dribble it counts this is my dribble
okay so that's a logo we made this one
actually we didn't that one is just like
a personal design but some of the other
ones are ones we made for companies
thank you yeah you made some of these
for company companies cool yeah yeah
that one's personal as well the that was
actually for a friend but the
creative yeah Ryan creative yeah that
was for that was for a company called a
Q sense cool and the idea was that we
kind of this niche market where we would
get basically really technical founders
coming out of great universities who had
these amazing ideas but didn't really
know how to present them to investors
and stuff like that so we'd ohm and I
would take those in this is vis yeah
this is a company I think they're
actually doing really great now and that
logos up on their website and everything
COFA other security company allocate we
really love that one really great
company to work with and those those
were a lot of fun because you know they
would come in with nothing right they've
come in with ads like 16 yeah I think we
were I think we were Sept 16 16 16 year
olds were we're designing the logos and
decks for the yeah the big pitches
yeah the pitches for we had we had one
at Y Combinator a couple of Y Combinator
we had we are vis DAC went in front of
the FDA cuz they have to get FDA
approval and stuff like that and it's oh
it's all about these the stimuli young
ages because then this is why you get
certain kids that are right making the
designs and doing the you know
competitions and and all this other kind
of great creates absolutely versus ones
that are yeah that haven't gotten the
right nutrients yeah right so so love
for design that that kind of persisted
throughout throughout my life and having
the amazing partner of ohm working on
this stuff with him has just been
amazing because we kind of handle
different parts of the process and it's
an I think that's also another thing I
would say you know mentorship is super
important but also having kind of
collaborators to work on things with and
have someone to bounce ideas off of
because literally and we always say this
to each other because you know now we're
on college and we have to call and stuff
like that but you know our best ideas
come when we're talking to each other
you know I'll I'll have an idea or he'll
have an idea but it's only really when
the other person hears it and is able to
say oh that reminds me this or that that
it really goes to the next level of
being something amazing you have to have
a good
this player on the other side because if
it's just mundane convo it's not gonna
be a good round of right idea tennis and
so you know I'm working with him on on
the new projects that were working on
and with ohm still with home still and
we're with with one of my a couple other
of my really good friends who are kind
of specialized in different different
fields and you did some neuroscience
work with CMU it's a science work yeah I
was I was really interested in
human-computer interaction so kind of
the way that we're interacting with
technology and I I thought about it a
lot and I was like alright I think the
way this is going is that brain computer
interfaces are gonna be kind of the
thing so I wanted to really understand
that so I went to see him you which is
where they're doing some of the like
really cutting-edge stuff they tried to
get the PIO was working with for neural
link for Elon Musk neuro-link and he was
like I'm just gonna stay and really work
on this thing myself
so he really incredible guy Mason
Chapman's are Persian guy at CMU in the
Department of Electrical Engineering I
think and they were doing these probes
for for brain stimulation and recording
and that really you know I went there I
said I emailed him I said hey I'm I do a
bunch of design stuff it looks like
you're doing a grant proposal I can do
the diagrams for your grant proposal
I don't I'm okay at biology I mean I
don't really have any formal training in
it but I just want to come and learn
from you guys but I'll do design for you
that's what I'll give and you can help
teach me about this and so I went there
and I designed their diagrams so for
their great proposal yeah which they
sent to the National Science Foundation
I think they got it they got like you
know a lot of money for it which was
really really cool and that kind of goes
back to you know taking the complex idea
and making it something
but kind of got Ronnie okay if we chat a
little longer you're asking me yeah am i
okay
am i okay with that you down you got any
money yeah yeah yeah okay I keep keep
keep rolling yeah let's um let's let's
go to you know you're you're speaking on
you know you were doing the designs and
the designs were going not a grant
proposal which is very exciting and she
learned a lot about you know neurosis
the eyes and kind of freaked out
honestly because I was like whoa this
this is actually could be real scary you
know we actually got this stuff to work
you're not even living in the real world
anymore this isn't even a VR headset
this is like you know complete
simulation right this is this is your
this is your brain in there getting
stimulation not from the world so I was
like we're getting into some really
weird territory so I actually got really
kind of scared and turned off from a lot
of those ideas that I think a lot of
people are really fascinated with about
oh you know full simulation full brain
computer interface I was actually seeing
it in person and seeing kind of some of
the tests that are doing with rats and
the rats were living completely
different reality you know thinking it's
hot when it's not hot thinking they're
supposed to run in circles all sorts of
crazy stuff I was like okay this is this
is not where I want to be going I think
I want to operate in the real world with
real people and stuff like that so a lot
of my focus changed to to stuff like the
house system like real systems like
physical systems of people like kind of
these human operating systems that can
lead to kind of these these amazing
experiences that I was able to
experience growing up and really
expanding that for for a lot of other
people so that's the that's kind of the
major project I'm working on now with
omen and with my other friends is it's
the Pantheon is the collective of people
working on this stuff so that's like you
know me oh my friend Jeremy and
summer homes how does what you made with
the house system at nueva school how
does that mm how does that become
pantheon in the real world how does how
does you know me s 1:26 have a little
family with some of us 24 22 that's 20
you know how do we have that right how
do we all men to reach out there yeah so
so the idea so that the basic the basic
like hitch if you will behind the big
idea behind the pantheon is is is that
thing that culture is getting pulled
apart and that you know we are going
into college we're gonna leave college
and then what are we going to be chasing
right we're gonna be chasing money we're
gonna be chasing status and we're gonna
be chasing comfort or that's at least
what we're kind of incentivized to chase
and what a lot of other people around us
are chasing right the problem with those
three things is that they Plateau right
you get to a certain level of income you
get to a certain level of comfort you
get to a certain level of status and
this is after your basic needs are met
of course and you get to those levels
and you realize you know it's not
actually that much better to go from a
small boat to a big boat it's not that
much different to go from a nice house
to a mansion you know that those things
you know they they make you real excited
the first year the second year third
year fourth year are you still getting
the same fulfillment right you got to
understand though our your that's a
great attitude but it's we have to wait
for people to kind of possibly just you
know die off there's a lot of people
that just don't have you know they want
to just keep going and get more and
right at a bigger boat so you thank you
so much for realizing that it just
doesn't work that way that's not in our
best interest we're destroying the
planet were throwing each other right so
keep up the good work again the world is
counting on you how do you get sustained
meaning so so how do you get to see me
that's the question of filming right so
if the if the curve is plateauing if the
curve of fulfillment is plateauing from
these other means and i think people
know this I really think it's only a
couple people kind of at the top who
want this thing to keep going I think
kids my age kids going to college you
know people your people older than you
they're not like saying oh yeah this is
working great for me I'm feeling super
satisfied with my life right now I'm
gonna fight tooth and nail until it goes
away you know they're they're saying I
want to live a good life I want to you
know exist and have kids and and you
know eat good food and have a nice time
watch a couple of Netflix shows you know
people aren't trying to break put a hole
in the system and then end up in a in
Turkey like so you need I think a new
model as opposed to just saying the
current model sucks yeah I think a lot
of people over history nobody's buying
it we're trying to do it in legislation
and people got their head rammed so far
up their ass we're waiting for leaders
to get us out of this mess and so I
think that's why you can't you can't
wait for those people to do it and
that's why we're trying to do it
ourselves so the idea is that the things
that really do fulfill people are
autonomy having autonomy which is having
the ability to do what you want to do
and kind of have kind of variation in
your life you know people on these
little commute circles where they wake
up they get in the train they get to
work they come home seeing the same for
people it's really not that interesting
you don't have that much autonomy to
break out of it you new exhibit opens at
the Natural History Museum
I love natural museums could want to go
see it you know my my partner is gonna
be like what are you doing you're gonna
leave me and the kids at home to go see
a naturist Museum right that's not how
it works
right but it was a family but you live
but you live in a communion it's
different so I'll get to that so what
time is really important having a
purpose something that gets you up in
the mornings really exciting that that's
really important having mastery being
good at a skill yeah is really important
some of the happiest people around me
are people that have a really good skill
my correct my friend own incredible
designer right you can he can always
fall back on that skill no matter what
happens he's always gonna have that my
friend Jeremy incredible mechanical
engineer right he knows he has an idea
he can get down to it get in the shop
you know in a couple days have something
working same thing with ohm and that's
incredibly deeply deeply deeply
fulfilling as opposed to people who have
never been encouraged to follow
something that interest them have been
told that that won't get you to college
or that won't help you in life or what
ever you know I think a lot of people
would look until telomer Jeremy you know
why you because these stuff start when
you're a kid that's right this stuff
starts when I'm sitting there sketching
stuff for Jeremy's you know tinkering
with stuff it's the parent letting them
do that or the teachers letting them do
that or fostering that or say Oh have
you heard about this or have you heard
about that and bring them along that
path and having mastery that's the thing
so autonomy purpose and having mastery
is so so so crucial to fulfillment yeah
because it allows you to actually
achieve your purpose a lot of people
have purposes right a lot of people
don't have the mastery required to
achieve that purpose and that's and
that's a problem
so autonomy purpose mastery and the last
two things which are equally important
interesting that someone can get purpose
fine seek something that brings the
meaning but then the this mastery the
steel says the means to get to that
purpose it doesn't exist and that's
incredibly dissatisfying and that can
almost be worse than not having a
purpose because you have a purpose
you're really passionate about a cause
and you don't know how to do anything
about it terribly terribly terribly
demoralizing gives you a feeling of
helplessness is really bad so having the
mastery along with the purpose is really
crucial and then the fourth thing
belonging feeling like you're part of a
community feeling that people love you
and appreciate you not just because of
the work that you produce or the SAT
scores that you produce or you know the
grades that you get but really can look
you in the eyes and to say I love you I
accept you kind of unconditionally and
that's that's a real sense of belonging
and that's really important for people I
think a lot of people today feel like
they're commodified on Instagram for
their looks for the places they've been
for the things they've done I think
people just want to at the end of the
day be loved right and just be seen and
that's a true sense of belonging and
that doesn't take 500 followers that
doesn't take 10,000 followers right
doesn't take any number but that takes
one person that takes two people that
takes five people that are around you
that you can always fall back on and you
know that's not kind of where we're
going with these social media systems
that are incentivizing you ton of
followers that don't care about your
rate it's it's really about those close
conditions so belonging and the last one
gratitude you you know you have that up
on your wall right there and it's true
you don't you can have all these things
you can have every
you want in the world but if you don't
sit down and look around you and say you
know I'm so thankful to be here I'm so
thankful for the people who've got me
here for the opportunity you know even
me sitting out you know I'm probably
grateful to be able to even talk about
these stories and have my mom have taken
me to all these places and have you know
amazing brothers and friends like omen
Jeremy who have been there for me and
nurtured me and you know to have met you
and to be able to talk about these
experiences is I'm incredibly grateful
for that and that's incredibly
fulfilling right it's incredibly
fulfilling there's an effect called the
doubling effect and when I look at my
hand I think it's part seventeen of the
optical cortex that's being fired if I
closed my eyes if I think about my hand
it's part seventeen of the optical
cortex being fired at a lesser capacity
buts being fired
the idea is you experience a beautiful
moment certain things are happening in
your mind you think about it later you
journal about it you write it down you
think about it
same feelings are being fired so you're
doubling the happiness you got from that
that's twice the amount of happiness
that you're ready having just because of
gratitude right that's incredibly
incredibly incredibly fulfilling yeah so
those are kind of the five the five
pillars you have autonomy you have
purpose you have mastery you have
belonging and then you have gratitude
and then so the question is what is a
life look like that's based on those
principles the solution that kind of
we've come up with at this time and
we're doing a lot of validation of it
we're going to be trying to test it out
the idea is that you make a community of
real people not not digitally you get up
to 150 people in one in one space and
that's because 150 people is the is the
is their name from part number yeah do
part number Dunbar Dunbar number yeah
yeah
so the Dunbar number archaea law are key
ologists have seen this when looking at
Paleolithic communities colonialists saw
this when they encountered
hunter-gatherers and the 1800s that the
bans were about 150 modern analyses of
the human neocortex have shown that you
can only keep track of about a hundred
50 people on a deep level so that's kind
of our number that's as far as we want
to make your immediate community
be so get 150 people in a in a basically
in a house like I mean in a big
community thing we don't really have
spaces that look like this so you say a
house people are like oh that's super
cramped it's not a house that's more you
would have to be designed differently
the best summer of love hippie [ __ ]
though that they just try to I you know
they did their best to get rid of that
and they did it is it is and I Charlie
Manson took care of that [ __ ] the the
problem is is I think they did a little
unrealistically in the way that they did
it and I'll explain why because they
isolated themselves from the rest of
society and I think we can't do that yes
you can't do it this time
you can't build this in the middle of
nowhere no yeah this is like this is
another 50 150 150 150 else
it sells right yeah we actually called
the atomic system because 150 people is
the atom then you put multiple atoms
next to each other you get a molecule
put multiple molecules next to each
other
you got a cell you put multiple cells
next to each other you get an organism
things based on nature usually work out
you know the best and we're kind of
going with that model so the idea is
that you have 150 people in this space
and you might be like wait the old-style
community how does that give you
autonomy right don't you have all these
obligations that you wouldn't have as an
individual it's actually a little bit
different than that because like I said
when you're in a nuclear family so much
is resting on your shoulders you're the
breadwinner right you're the parent
you're the mentor of the kid you're the
enforcer right you're the playmate
you're everything for this kid you're
everything for your partner you're
everything for the household right
there's this enormous weight on your
shoulders and when you're in a community
you have other kids that can be the
playmates of the kids you have other
parents that can be the mentors of the
kids you have other people that can be
stepping in beta beta 2 Sigma what is it
you believe do you say boom to said yeah
right you have these other people doing
those things you know I get a communal
the communal impact you taking care of
each other
yeah thinking a little bit of the burden
absolutely off this is this is very cool
autonomy autonomy purpose purpose
mass a longing gratitude
belonging gratitude man those just
couple lines of code embedded into
everywhere around the world would be
great yeah yeah and just making a social
fabric that can handle that
right those five and right how do you
envision the implementation of the
Pantheon into the you know because you
have to enter new code
yeah the old into the old code and then
yeah make people removal yeah to want to
move into the yeah so new code and you
know there I could go into detail about
kind of a lot of the interior systems
we've thought about it how do you
educate kids in the system how do you
work in the system we have a system
called the amplify team system that is
how we do work and I could you know I
could talk forever about this stuff and
I'm really excited right now and would
talk to you forever all dressed so I
won't go into all that hopefully we'll
have all that stuff online at some point
okay online and we can put a link in the
bottom we can that's done yeah and then
where would you want to do a first I
want to I want to unpack that with you
at another show yeah we could show but
yeah so basically this summer we're
doing that the test run of it so we're
gonna we're gonna go out into the world
we're gonna go to some of the blue zones
was that mean blue zones are the places
where people live the longest they're
there like five pockets are yeah okinawa
there's one in Sardinia there's one in
Greece we're thinking of going to some
of these places hands-on kind of the
design thinking model of user testing
when talking to people learning
interviewing them documenting this
process real doing trying to do real
research on what's making these people's
lives so fulfilling to validate our
assumptions that those five things are
really important because those are I
know I didn't pull those oh yeah is that
a no where I throw the books and studies
and stuff that you've collated or you
know coalesced yet collapse
but you know we want to also get some
hands-on experiential beautiful
testimonial stuff yes and then do that
for a couple of weeks out really out in
the world then come sit down and say so
how are we going to edit our existing
model that we've thought of how are we
going to adapt it to the number of
people that we have or the constraints
that we have this summer making a
prototype and then running that probably
in Silicon Valley in a house with the
people that we can gather this summer
who are excited about the idea and
testing it and documenting documenting
how it goes documenting if we do feel
that sense of belonging if we do feel
that sense of autonomy and really trying
to be honest with ourselves about it
because if we're wrong we don't want to
live in that society for act right so
trying to be as honest as we can about
that process that reminds us a lot about
what we were learning for exactly you
and Jeremy and Conrad exactly lot
interdependent capitalism a lot of the
blood of that strengthening of the
social fabric the inclusive fitness the
inclusive stake holding of communities
yet each other it's a lot of what
certain you know Kanawa and I feel like
a propagating that more around the world
right is a fantastic fantastic idea and
just will help so much with a lot of
ailments that we see develop that you
know yeah so prototyping at this summer
and working on our own kind of like
startup projects that are a kind of
social impact minded during that time
and those kind of being able to generate
capital for the future for future things
so the panel's cuz holding company we
have kind of these ventures that we're
doing but we're also prototyping this
communities the ventures you know
provide resources to make the community
run so this summer you hope to do this
the after research to do the to live
live in in a prototype prototype
prototype community okay and then work
on an actual business that's like kind
of unrelated but that you provide funds
that to do that great and we would like
to cover that yeah let's yeah
or how that's going I'd be great let's
cover the research that you did be
fantastic and then you know if that
works or if it doesn't work regrouping
from that and then testing out things
over the next few summers and then when
we're out of college you know doing it
doing it for an extended period of time
not just a summer but but you know
seeing if we can do it for a year two
years depending on the model that we've
created I'm sure it'll be different by
that time because we'll have learned so
much from our own experience and from
the experience of others but that's how
we do it in the real world is we we
actually physically make the community
and there are a lot of people I talked
to at Stanford who are excited about the
idea there are a lot of friends you know
around the world and around the u.s.
they're excited about the idea so we
just really need to validate it we
really need to say yep this actually
works and then I think other people will
be ready to make the job and say okay
you know I'm I could do something else
with my summer or I still can be an
internet wherever during the summer but
I'm gonna live in this community as
opposed to my own apartment I'm gonna
I'm gonna adopt this model and that's
the idea is that it's not like a
business it's not a company or anything
it's just like a framework for how to
live and if we're able to validate it
yes and people can take it and kind of
put their own spins on correct that's
that's a very crucial part taking the
framework and being deployed wherever
we're ready right around the world
Bangladesh you know Japan
Syria any I mean anywhere you want to do
it yes hopefully it's malleable enough
that those people it can adapt to their
religion there yes yes way of life the
resources on hand yes yes beautiful
beautiful I've really said to follow up
on that I mean we we have a ton more to
talk about
we didn't that we didn't get to we we do
have to yeah we'll have to save that
especially Ishmael
yes I'm that that's a very exciting book
that I think you and I were having a
great great conversation about slowing
down and really thinking about every
seed that is being born into the world
and giving them giving that the right
nutrients to our
and that's why we see this paper
airplane that's kind of like instead of
a very robust one right yeah it's a very
quick and some people propose that those
are the challenges that is kind of the
anyway get into that and we can still
get into all the little micro gradients
of the of the generations my generations
which is so interesting to and what's
happening so we'll have to have you back
on to explore all that on the way out
you know obviously this is an image a
beautiful image of the cosmos so we are
going to ask you do you think we are
alone in the cosmos
maybe yeah I think maybe I think there's
a good chance that the great filter is
what we're going through right now and
that if we don't adapt if we don't free
culture from the place that's being torn
in that that's a fundamental axiom of
what happens when civilizations think
they're better than the circle of I
think they're better than the earth and
it kills them so I think if we don't
adapt yep we're gonna we're definitely
you know not gonna not gonna be showing
ourselves to other civilizations and
maybe that's what's happened before is
they when you get to a certain level of
technological evolution you can't
overcome you know the basic biological
stuff and it pulls you apart so maybe
that's a great filter I mean of course
we're in the tiny arm of the galaxy so
we wouldn't really be close to the
cultural center anyways but for my
argument yes we are alone yeah yeah the
Fermi filter is such a fascinating
conversation that we'll talk about more
yeah all right next question
this is simulation so we must ask you
are we in a simulation
is is it okay to say it doesn't matter
if we are please explain because I think
obviously the name of the shows the
simulation and I absolutely love the
work you guys doing here so I'm not
gonna attack the concept of do we live
in the simulation
oh wait and that's not even the central
thesis of wine-red show is called it
right but I think you know people liked
it like really get down and think about
our witness simulation I just think the
implications of it aren't that relevant
like there are people dying in the world
there are people depressed and anxious
and deeply hurt and you know lonely in
the world I think that's a much more
interesting problem to tackle is like
what's happening to us
in the simulation regardless of it's a
simulation or not you know we're not
doing too well so how do we how do we
work on that so I think you still don't
know if everything outside of you is
real though that's true yeah maybe I
need to reflect on myself try and make
the world a better place yeah because
exactly you level up period no matter
what right level up you know make the
world better no matter what yeah yes
emulation or not you know this is what
we have so so level the hell up so let's
okay last question what is the most
beautiful thing in the world
the love of a mother
hands up
and on every level right I mean that
like like Homo sapiens like my mom but I
also mean like mother earth right yeah
not to get too too out there but well
you had a pretty dope mother you know
you were talking about her earlier she
was quite my dad yeah Marvin Gaye got
shot when he just dent his mother's dad
shot him like the next day did you were
you aware that you know Marvin Gaye is
sure you think that's mother and then
did this father shot him dead knocks on
my dad yeah yeah yeah so so yeah mother
then mother earth and yeah I mean that's
the gift of life you generalife yeah
yeah yeah yeah Wow
you know I love love smart young people
I love it it gives us so much whole like
yourself I mean good news yeah and I
thought that uh and I thought that yeah
but there's there's something very very
special about you know hearing you speak
this way it's so so special and I think
with more opportunities for young people
to travel to do things like the wave of
school to do things like that you will
absolutely I think and with this really
strong multidisciplinary deep time
perspective on reality I think we're in
good hands as yeah as long as we can get
that out to more and more young people
that are being born that's good I mean
that's what this show is doing yeah I
mean we need to get these writings up
online that's right that's right that's
right
this has been such a pleasure thank you
really yeah yeah
this is Victor Danson thank you so much
I love loved having you unleash yourself
on this program thank you yes thank you
for giving you beautiful
to pop in full beautiful beautiful
beautiful yeah as we were saying this
Cassandra we are adopting you please
yeah you are you are officially more
Mentors yeah we are being adopted we are
you know your students as well so yeah
that's absolutely thank you thank you
everyone for tuning in we love that
you've been with us this long we would
love to hear from you in the comments
below please let us know your thoughts
have more conversations with people
around you about the conversations that
we were having and add your own spin and
taste to them huge shout out to Ron
Vargas for producing and directing we
love you so much Ronny and support the
artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe in everyone you know ah Riesling
Saar below are links are below support
us help people manifest their dreams
into the world manifest your own dreams
into the world go build go create we
love you so very much thank you for
tuning in build the future peace
[Music]